all right Pokemon HQ let's take our most
popular character recreate him in loving
detail cast the Internet's favorite
voice of sarcasm adhere to established
Canon and drop in a lot of Easter eggs
to fans of this series movie I choose
you
meanwhile over at Sonic HQ yeah guys
let's do it they did but change
everything about the character remove
any ties to established lore and set the
whole thing to classic gangster rap come
on money
hello Internet welcome to film theory
the show that's kinda cringy when it
tries to be funny but at the end of the
day is still endearing just like
detective Pikachu
hey so based on the Internet's
collective reaction it seems like we
finally got ourselves the first great
video game movie of all time don't
overcook it it's fun it's good it's
enjoyable it's about as good as a
live-action Pokemon film could be and
probably say it's the first watchable
videogame movie okay dialing back the
praise here the first watchable
videogame movie of all time
No in all honesty I saw it last night
and I have to agree it was just a lot of
fun nothing groundbreaking but it was
just a really enjoyable movie to watch
and as an experience it confirmed a lot
of things for me Ryan Reynolds still
funny Pikachu still adorable mr. mime
still probably creeping on kids at night
but more so than any of that detective
Pikachu seems to have provided the final
pieces of evidence needed to confirm one
of the longest-running and coolest
Pokemon theories that's been taken
around since the first generation of
games way back in the 90s in the process
of solving the mystery of what happened
to Tim Goodman's father detective
Pikachu may have also just solved a much
more important mystery a case that's
been open for over 20 years a case whose
solution has huge implications about the
true nature of Pokemon so pull out your
magnifying glasses and put on that
deerstalker cap because we've got
ourselves a case to solve a case begins
with the video games way back in 1998
year when everyone thought that they
were king of the world and the height of
mobile gaming was an 8-bit egg in your
pocket named Tam
gachi little did we know then that we
were in the middle of a revolution the
pokken revolution generation 150 cute
little pocket monsters that would give
rise to the highest-earning media
franchise of all time eat your heart out
Hello Kitty two years earlier in 1996
the world had been met with pokemons red
green and blue but that came pokemon
yellow in 1998 which contained one major
change Pikachu is now your starter
Pokemon just followed you around the
overworld that was pretty much it other
minor changes were to make it feel
closer to the hugely popular anime
series at the time the gym leader
Giovanni using a Persian word characters
like Jessie and James replacing generic
team rocket grunt appearances but other
than that it was just the original games
all over again or was it you see there
was one other very subtle change made in
Pokemon yellow in the course of your
journey across the Kanto region you
visit a place called the pokémon mansion
on Cinnabar Island a massive building
filled with rubble scattered throughout
it our journal entries referencing the
discovery of MU in the journals of
Guiana and the subsequent creation of
the ultra powerful ultra violent mu to
the wreckage around the mansion is the
game's way of telling us that he was
created here and later escaped something
that later games in particular the
recent let's go Pikachu and Eevee series
makes a lot more explicit you eventually
find Mewtwo in the cerulean cave where
he can finally be caught but here's the
important change in pokemon yellow a new
wild pokemon can be found roaming the
halls of the mansion ditto the transform
Pokemon a little blob of purple goo
unique for its ability to shape-shift
using DNA as his pokedex entry says
capable of copying an enemy's genetic
code to instantly transform itself into
a duplicate of the enemy seems like it's
just a minor shift in spawn locations
right maybe it seemed to many to be more
than just a coincidence that a
genetically based Pokemon would appear
in an area where Mewtwo was being
created using genetic experimentation
perhaps there was a way that ditto was
connected to both Mew Mew 2 made
just maybe dittos were the failed clones
of mute the experiments that didn't make
the cut until science was finally able
to create the perfect new clone in
Mewtwo seems like it's a bit of a
stretch
rice purists like me grasping at straws
all they did was change one spawn
location but the closer you looked into
this thing the more details started to
line up the connection between the two
only got stronger when players noticed
that again in yellow the only other
spawn location for ditto was the
cerulean cave where Mewtwo winds up
hiding out after his escape from the
mansion so wherever Mewtwo was dittos
seemed to follow it was enough to get
theorists like me to start looking
closer and boy howdy did we ever find a
treasure trove of evidence the
similarities between Mew and ditto are
undeniable in the games to have the
exact same weight of 8.8 pounds they're
the only two Pokemon that are able to
learn the transform move purely by
levelling up even their coloration seems
to match I mean sure ditto is usually
purple and Mew is usually pink but
sometimes some iterations of the game
Mew is purple and sometimes in some
iterations of the games ditto is pink
and in detective Pikachu the ditto was
definitely much more in the pink
spectrum but there is no denying that
all the time both ditto and you have
shiny forms that are both the same shade
of light blue and this is all just the
superficial stuff if you dig further
into the game's data even the numbers
tell the story of how they're connected
each Pokemon has base stats that govern
their basic attributes like HP attack
defense speed etc mu is a regular
jack-of-all-trades when it comes to his
base stats he has equal base stats
across the board if you look at dittos
base stats you'll find the exact same
thing
identical base stat distribution across
the board
now all of dittos are 52 percent lower
than muse but it's exactly 52 percent
for all six of the main stats the
distribution of those statistics is
identical it's almost as if dito were a
weaker copy of the original mew and that
there's the point
dito isn't Mew it's an imperfect copy
it's the result of failed cloning
experiments cloning experiments
eventually give rise to Mewtwo and leave
the little pile of gooey DNA ditto over
there in the corner wandering around
looking for stuff to do
kind of a weird Pokemon all of it adds
up to a very compelling amount of
circumstantial evidence but for the two
decades since yellows release that's all
it's been circumstantial a bunch of
similarities never outright confirmed by
any singular piece of Pokemon media and
then came detective Pikachu let's lay
out what we learned from the movie and
yes we're gonna have to have some minor
spoilers here not the big twist of what
happened to Tim's father or anything
like that but for the smaller mysteries
that are uncovered along the way I'll
give you three seconds so you can use
that time to click away and/or click the
subscribe button to get notified of
every time we have a cool Theory like
this one help this channel get to 10
million subscribers please it would be
great to get that glorified paperweight
alright we all good everyone is sure
who's gonna shore fantastic within the
movie it's mentioned that Mewtwo is a
genetically altered clone of the ancient
pokémon Mew confirming everything that
we just talked about but the movie goes
one step further they explicitly say
that Mewtwo disappeared from the Kanto
region 20 years ago now the Kanto region
is where the first games took place and
where the anime began interesting
coincidence but nothing earth-shattering
it's that 20 years detail that really
matters you see detective Pikachu is
coming out just over 20 years after the
release of the generation 1 games and
exactly 20 years after the release of
pokémon Mewtwo strikes back the first
ever Pokemon movie which was all about
you guessed it Mewtwo's escape it's all
connected and that's not even
speculation it is something outright
confirmed by the screenwriters in an
interview they did with polygon quote
the implication which the screenwriters
confirmed to polygon is that this is the
same Mewtwo from the Canon Universe end
quote I mean I gotta quibble with them
saying dull can and universe because
it's like which Canon universe are you
talking about but hey I will take it so
we have an established and confirmed
canonical connection between detective
Pikachu and the wider Pokemon franchise
cool but the writers went on in another
interview this
with Screen Rant to confirm that they
were aware of the ditto Mew theories
when working on the project quote again
so we went into the history of ditto we
looked at all of those things and we
kind of wanted to leave it up to the
audience of people that are more
familiar with the story we didn't
necessarily feel that we wanted to go
too much into that but all of those
things are a factor and I think the deep
origin of ditto is a provocative
question that we wanted to hint at
because of the interaction with Mewtwo's
genetic material it did seem like there
was a sensible connection between MU 2
and the ditto so we have writers who've
been approved to work within the
official canon who were also aware of
the possible connection between ditto
and mute so now the question is how does
that actually translate to what we see
on screen well in the movie we see ditto
playing a pivotal role by the end of the
film it's revealed that Howard Clifford
the founder of rhyme City is our true
villain a man who's out to hijack
Mewtwo's mind so he can gain the psychic
pokemons powers for himself in order to
do this he uses his partner pokemon
ditto
but this isn't any ordinary ditto you
see Howard's ditto has the ability to
transform at will and in the film's
climax we see him do exactly that he
transforms into a champ to beat up Tim
then transforming into a cubone to give
him a few knuckle taps to knock him off
a building and later transforming into a
raging Charizard hack his ditto can even
transform into humans which is a whole
other discussion for another day all of
these behaviors though directly conflict
with what we know about a normal day
doze abilities we're told repeatedly
throughout the animes and video games
that ditto can only copy things it sees
in gameplay terms this means that ditto
can't just transform into any random
Pokemon it always has to copy whatever
enemy it's facing but this isn't just a
gameplay mechanic it is something that's
a part of this wider franchises canon as
established via various pokedex entries
ruby and sapphire emerald diamond and
pearl black and white ditto
rearranges itself structure to transform
itself into other shapes however if it
tries to transform itself into something
by relying on its memory this pokemon
manages to get details wrong a ditto
rearranges itself structure to transform
itself however
if it tries to change based on its
memory it will get details wrong it has
the ability to reconstitute its entire
cellular structure to transform into
whatever it sees this is further
supported by what we see in the anime
the first ditto we meet in the anime are
the ones belonging to the copycat
duplicate and in her episodes we learned
that ditto are only capable of
transforming into Pokemon that are
physically present and that this is a
limitation of the species as a whole
likewise all the other episodes that
have ditto only show ditto transforming
into Pokemon that are present for it to
copy across all of our research there
were zero canonical cases of ditto
randomly shape-shifting at will without
having a Pokemon nearby to copy so far
Howard's ditto and detective Pikachu to
cycle between forms so rapidly and so
precisely forms that it's not seeing and
is still able to replicate flawlessly it
must be some kind of super ditto
something that we haven't seen in this
series before something that was
artificially birthed out of a laboratory
off of Mewtwo's genetics remember that
all this time the working theory that
we've been trying to prove is the
connection between Mewtwo and ditto that
like Mewtwo ditto was also born out of
the same genetic testing now in
detective Pikachu twenty years later we
see ditto and Mewtwo connected yet again
Howard Clifford is doing genetic
experiments on Mewtwo and outskirts of
Rhyme City and in the process produces a
ditto with powers that surpass the other
members of its species Tim says what
kind of data was that that was one of my
father's genetic experiments if you were
looking for the final piece of
confirmation for the link between new
Mewtwo and ditto this is it and probably
as explicit as we're ever gonna get
ditto is made out of the genetic stuff
that Mew and u2 are also made out of it
is more possible now than ever that
ditto is just a bunch of failed
protoplasm coming out of Mew cloning
experiments back in 1998 it was all
about creating the first forms of Mewtwo
and the random regular dittos that
spawned out of that process now 20 years
later in 2019 with detective Pikachu
it's elevating and exploiting Mewtwo's
powers for the next level of Howard
Clifford's evolution and in the process
he's Cree
a stronger more advanced form of ditto
in the end it took a film theory to
confirm one of the most famous game
theories of all time but hey that's just
a theory a multimedia cross-platform
theory and if you want to see more on
detective Pikachu check out my film
theory on why detective Pikachu himself
might actually be Ash's Pikachu the
movie doesn't outright D confirm it an
act you really likes riding on Tim's
shoulders the whole time or hop on over
to my other channel game theory for some
more Pokemon excitement I have over 20
episodes theorizing everything from how
geography affects evolution in the
Pokemon series to dead Pokemon and what
happens in heck this last weekend
actually did one exposing the true story
behind one of the mysterious ghost girls
that haunts the Pokemon games in fact
I'm gonna link to the whole Pokemon
playlist right here so you can just
binge watch Pokemon theories to your
heart's content so now if you'll excuse
me I got to go catch them all catch all
the other big release movies that hit in
like a one month span there's a lot to
watch that I have to get through so need
to run back to the theater now that this
episode is done hopefully produces some
good theories